The security of a device
should be established
when the device is turned on initially.
IOS uses trusted bootchain
to achieve this goal.
When an iOS is turned on,
each application processor immediately
executes code from boot only
memory known as the bootrom.
This immutable code known as
the hardware root of trust,
is laid down during chip fabrication and
is implicitly trusted.
In other words,
this code is brunt into the hardware.
The bootrom code contains
the Apple root CA public key,
which is used to verify
that the low level loader,
LLB is signed by Apple properly
before allowing it to load.
This is the first step in the chain
of trust where each step ensures that
the next is signed by Apple properly.
When the LLB finishes its tasks,
it verifies and
runs the next stage below the iBoot.
Which in turn verifies and
runs the iOS kernel.
This secure bootchain helps ensure that
the lowest levels of software
are not tampered with.
And allows iOS to run only
on validated Apple devices.